une tentative d'assassinat en plein
centre commercial à Amboise ça s'est
passé samedi deux septuagénr ont été
blessés par un individu avec un couteau
de bouché en plein hypermarché l'homme
qui affiche des antécédents judiciaires
s'en serait pris avec préméditation au
couple pour le moment son mobile reste
inconnu il pourrait s'agir du règlement
d'un différent entre eux les détails
avec Clémence doque l'auteur de
l'agression a été maîtrisé par un
employé de la cafétéria où se sont
produit les faits âgé d'une cinquantaine
d'années il a porté plus coups de
couteau à un couple âé qu'il connaissait
l'homme et la femme atteint à la tête au
thorax et au cou ont été transportés
rapidement vers l'hôpital Trousseau
suite aux premières constatations et
audition la tentative d'omicide avec
préméditation a été retenue si le mis en
cause reconnaît les faits son mobile
n'est pas clairement
établi dans un communiqué de la
procureur de la République il est
indiqué que l'auteur est déjà connu de
la justice pour des faits en lien avec
la réglementation routière de plus il
était placé sous contrôle judiciaire
depuis octobre suite à des menaces à
l'encontre de son ex-compagne dès 15h30
samedi l'auteur de l'agression a été
placée en garde à vue celle-ci a été
prolongée la journée de dimanche et la
brigade de recherche de la gendarmerie
d'Amboise a été saisie selon le parquet
de tour il a été déféré ce lundi
après-midi pour une saisine du juge
d'instruction l'arme utilisée un couteau
de bouchée était toujours en cours
d'analyse ce
dimanche